this is a production of Cornell
University
thank you Chris good afternoon everybody
it's really my honor to be here and
speak with you today and now that we've
heard about all of these wonderful
veggies and fruits it's upon us with
Francis to bring them to your table and
try to preserve that goodness and that
freshness and I'm going to just tell you
some of the things that we do in food
science to make that happen
now food we do take for granted
oftentimes and we do have as consumers
big expectations when it comes to food
and I try to let here some of the most
important elements that are expected
from food some we think about some we
don't like safety we take it for granted
we buy it from the store we think yes
it's got to be safe from time it's
easier to have it safe than other times
and as food scientists now quite a bit
about that and work in that area so what
we do in food science touches on pretty
much all of these points here safety
nutrition and that's wholesomeness of
the food that gives us enjoyment to
we're trying to work on that too and
then also when we apply these methods of
manufacturing or processing we're trying
to do it in a sustainable
environmentally friendly way and there
are more and more efforts in that area
at Cornell we do work primarily on fruit
and vegetable products and dairy product
but we touch pretty much all food
commodities and I try to capture them on
the slide here I can't forget this
because we are actually speaking of
enjoyment now where we're working in
those areas and they have become quite
popular just a few examples of some of
the work that happens in food science
safety I mentioned earlier that often
times consumers take the you know for
granted and it should be there it should
be in the foods that you buy in the
supermarket or in the local market but
there are things that happen to the food
where it can get contaminated with
bacteria that can make us sick so as a
program we're looking at first of all
how bacteria can get into foods and what
are the bacteria that can make us sick
and how can we prevent them from getting
into our food and we've had programs
like this very successful for for many
years and I just brought it except for
you to see that we are getting
recognition we're getting national and
international recognition for some of
that work our dairy team our dairy
microbiologist and the board has helped
build that program have helped over the
years both consumers and the industry
with achieving safety but we're here to
talk today about what's coming up new
so-called revolution I well I don't know
if we can call it exactly revolution but
certainly we're leading some new ways in
which we can keep our food safe we're
working for instance on some materials
that one can use in manufacturing plants
to prevent bacteria from attaching and
then from from perpetuating this
contamination and you see here a photo
of some bacterial cells on a surface
that in my group we have developed
collaboratively with a group in nano
engineering that doesn't use any
chemicals that just uses the surface
features to prevent bacteria from
sticking to that surface so that in the
end we mitigate contamination and also
use less chemicals to clean the
equipment so it could be in the end a
more sustainable way of doing food
processing something that I'm personally
very excited about is what's happening
now in food science on our both
locations Attica and Geneva we have seen
in recent years an increased interest in
these alternatives new processes there's
not a sort of new processing
technologies where we rely less on heat
to treat the food to make it safe and
and last on the shelf so we do now have
a big initiative here at Cornell where
we are getting some of these new novel
technologies that enable us to keep food
safe without the use of heat or using
minimal heat and we do have for for
example this new high pressure treatment
technologies that we are using to kill
bacteria in certain foods and we have in
Geneva one of the best piece of
equipment that could could be at any
University actually I don't I'm not
aware of many places that have that that
help us help the industry maintain the
safety of foods and more about that in
in a little bit the longest thin line we
are getting some other technologies that
help us make new foods foods that are
fresher and these we hope will help us
restructure the way some foods are being
manufactured we've relied on feet for
you know many decades for centuries now
to make food and that's fine and heat is
actually sometimes you can't you can't
make a food safe without heat but we're
also looking at some of these novel
technologies that will allow us to use
different principles to make food just
one example that I want to show you
because you may not be even be aware
that you're buying already some of the
foods that are made using these
technologies I mentioned high pressure
what do I mean by that well imagine
putting the food on the bottom of the
ocean actually at the deepest point in
the ocean in the Mariana Trench you only
have about a sixth of the total pressure
that we can that we are using now in
food manufacturing to treat foods so
that bacteria is killed and it's been
successful for a number of products and
these are commercial
product that you might have bought and
you didn't realize that they were
treated with high pressures that's how
we can now buy fresh guacamole from from
the store and well it's processed but it
retains that freshness and the variety
of foods you see all of these well
highly expensive right now juices like
six dollar bottle of you know the Suge's
were naked juices all of these very cool
things your green juices that if you had
he treated them they certainly wouldn't
look like that they wouldn't taste as
fresh and they were made possible by
using these technologies
unfortunately correctly you can't put
you know strawberries in that high
pressure unit and still have them
maintain their structure but in in many
cases you can do that now what are we
doing here we're actually helping
understand better which microorganisms
you can kill using this technology which
foods you can make safe and also improve
their shelf life using this technology
and we're trying to also help industry
to adopt this technology in their own
plant but we're also trying to utilize
these new technologies in different ways
because you can now use raw products and
treat them with hydration really use
them to manufacture new types of food
products this is just an image of the
high pressure treatment unit that we
have in Geneva New York but what we are
doing for instance in in my program
right now we're understanding more and
more what the this treatment does to
different cause different chemical
compounds in foods different for
instance proteins so there are some
structural changes that happen and you
can actually take proteins from milk or
take proteins from your your pulses and
and other sources and expose them to
pressure you don't add any ingredients
you don't add any acid you don't add
heat and
yes you can obtain these interesting
structures here that you know you kind
of have a jello type product or yogurt
type product just by views of pressure
and we're leading the way in making
those things happen and these are not
products that you have on the Shelf
right now but we're hoping that will be
part of the making of these products in
the future and they will be both you
know interesting products retain
freshness nutrition and safe at the same
time and with that like to thank you for
your attention this has been a
production of Cornell University on the
web at cornell edu